online marketplace TaskRabbit finds
people willing to help with everyday
work the chores include assembling new
furniture washing dogs running errands
and even waiting in a line the company
currently performs tasks in nearly 30
cities in the US and UK this morning
TaskRabbit is announcing that is
expanding to 20 new cities next week
Detroit Raleigh Durham and Nashville
will be among the places to have the
service Stacy Brown Philpott is task
rabbits CEO she joined the company about
four years ago after spending nearly a
decade at Google welcome Stacy thank you
so this was founded the company in 2008
how does it work so you can download an
app and hire someone safe and reliably
to come and do chores around your house
so in just five minutes
you can find a trusted person who can
hang some shelves on a wall assemble
your IKEA furniture or if you're moving
help you move pack and unpack those
boxes
what's the vetting process how do we
know Stacy people coming into the home
are safe so all of our tasks goes go
through a very rigorous vetting process
that includes a background check at the
federal state local level they also get
screened of with their bank account and
so we know who they are and they verify
their identity so what are some of the
craziest things down because will they
really do anything number one I know
they won't do anything but will they do
most things and what's the craziest
thing that you've heard not anything
yeah most of our tasker's are handyman
or handy women we had a guy his basement
stairs collapsed and he fell and he was
okay so he pulls it in the task he was
okay but he was trapped in his basement
so he had his phone and he posted a task
on TaskRabbit to SAP somebody come build
stairs so he can get out of his basement
I didn't call 911 call 911 the most
important thing was to get out of the
basement
yeah so the task came and built the
stairs who can get out of this what's
the most frequent request the most
frequent request is I buy furniture from
Ikea or some other store and I need to
get it put together I think I can do it
myself but I really really deep down I
can't so
I hire somebody so the company you were
CEO for many years and then you made the
transition to CEO what was that
transition like for you
it was a pretty easy transition I found
her and knew each other really well the
hardest part was you become the CEO and
now you have to define a vision define
our strategy and lead people towards a
goal that way they don't know if there's
possible but they can reach their
potential is the essential thing to
scale up so that you have enough cities
in which you can perform absolutely we
want to be coast-to-coast and be coming
to the heartland of America which is
what this expansion is about is just
essentially doing that what else you got
the larger concerns about the gig
economy we have lots of other companies
like yours and I know there was one
TaskRabbit employee who was quoted in a
recent New Yorker piece who said these
are jobs that don't lead to anything it
doesn't feel sustainable to me
yeah well TaskRabbit is about job
creation every day what we get to do is
help people find meaningful work we have
30,000 people who show up on our site
every month who want to task on
TaskRabbit they make $35 an hour on
average which is five times the federal
minimum wage and so this is really about
earning a meaningful income in a
flexible way but is it a sustainable
income I mean you don't pay their
version of the social security taxes
healthcare all of those sorts of things
most of our tasker's are part-time they
have some other job that they're doing
it's a supplemental income and then we
offer access to benefits in a discount
so we offer access to health care we
offer access to 401k benefits we offer
access to tax planning and other things
at a discount but you grew up in Detroit
not exactly a hotbed of Silicon Valley
kind of things and you said growing up
you didn't really have access to black
CEOs or even women CEOs do you think
that that conversation is changing now I
do I grew up in the city of Detroit with
a single mom who didn't have a lot of
resources to take care of me and my
brother I wish TaskRabbit existed when
we were growing up but it didn't and so
I get to do this every day where people
can now come and find these jobs and so
the conversation is changing I'm the CEO
I'm a representative of what you can
become if you work hard and you focus on
on your education in the Clinton Silicon
Valley we're talking about it and I'm
glad that the conversations are
happening need to do more yeah thank you
good and it's a great company charlie
has asked me several times gitmo can i
how what's his TaskRabbit I could use
this
now we know now we know Thank You Stacy
brown Philpott